>> Sean: WE TOLD YOU
PRESIDENT TRUMP ANNOUNCED FRIDAY
HE WAS COMMUTING THE SENTENCE OF
ROGER STONE.
DAYS BEFORE, STONE WAS SET TO
START A THREE PLUS YEARS PRISON
SENTENCE STEMMING FROM ROBERT
MUELLER’S RUSSIAN WITCH HUNT.
ROGER STONE WAS CONVICTED OF
PROCESS CRIMES AND STATEMENTS TO
HOUSE LAWMAKERS.
IN OTHER WORDS, LONG BEFORE
CONGRESS.
ADAM SCHIFF PRESIDING.
THE BIGGEST LIAR IN CONGRESS.
NEITHER THE SCHIFF SHOW OR
ROBERT MUELLER PRODUCED ONE BIT
OF EVIDENCE THAT STONE WAS
WORKING WITH ANYBODY COLLUDING
WITH RUSSIA.
BY THE WAY, AS A WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SECRETARY EXPLAINED "THESE
CHARGES WERE THE PRODUCT OF
RECKLESSNESS BORN OF FRUSTRATION
AND MALICE."
JOINING US NOW, ROGER STONE,
FIRST TV INTERVIEW AND HIS
ATTORNEY, DAVID SHOWN.
I WOULD LIKE TO SAY TO YOU,
ROGER, I’M GLAD YOU HAD YOUR
SENTENCE COMMUTED AND YOU ARE
NOT HEADED TO PRISON THIS WEEK,
THERE IS A PART OF ME THAT’S
ALSO VERY ANGRY AND VERY
CONCERNED FOR THE COUNTRY.
BASED ON THE ENTIRE HANDLING OF
YOUR MATTER.
WHY DON’T I JUST LET YOU SAY IT
IN YOUR OWN WORDS WHAT THIS HAS
BEEN LIKE FOR YOU.
>> WELL, THIS IS THE MOST
HORRIBLE EXPERIENCE YOU CAN HAVE
BECAUSE I SEE IMMEDIATELY WHY
99% OF THE PEOPLE WHO CHOOSE TO
PLEAD NOT GUILTY AND GO TO TRIAL
LOSE.
WHEN YOU’RE UP AGAINST THE
HORRIFIC AND DEEP-POCKETED
RESOURCES OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND THESE REALLY
SADISTIC ARROGANT POLITICALLY
MOTIVATED PROSECUTORS, AND I HAD
A BIASED JUDGE.
I HAD A STACKED JURY.
I HAD A CORRUPT JURY FOR WOMAN.
AS MY FRIEND TUCKER CARLSON
SAID, MY TRIAL WAS OVER BEFORE
IT STARTED.
AND NOW WHEN YOU GO THROUGH
SOMETHING LIKE THIS, SEAN, YOU
FIND OUT WHO YOUR REAL FRIENDS
ARE AND WHO THE PEOPLE ARE WHO
REALLY NEVER WERE YOUR FRIENDS.
YOU HAD BEEN A TREMENDOUS
FRIEND.
YOU HAVE DONE A GREAT JOB OF
KEEPING PEOPLE INFORMED.
BUT I HAVE TO REALLY SINGLE OUT
YOUR FOX NEWS COLLEAGUE
TUCKER CARLSON.
HE TOOK UP THE CUDGELS EARLY.
HE STAYED ON THIS CASE WITH
EVERY TWIST AND TURN, WASN’T
AFRAID TO TAKE ON THE JUDGE.
LAID OUT THE JURY QUESTION,
ENCOURAGED ME WHEN I GOT
DISCOURAGED.
HE’S A MAN OF INCREDIBLE LOYALTY
AND HE’S A GREAT FRIEND.
HE MAY BE THE BEST FRIEND A MAN
CAN HAVE, SO MY HATS OFF TO HIM
AND ALSO CONGRESSMAN MATT GAETZ
FROM FLORIDA WHO I HOPE TO LIVE
LONG ENOUGH TO SEE IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
HE WAS A GREAT FRIEND WHO NEVER
GAVE UP AND TRIED TO MAKE SURE
EVERYBODY UNDERSTOOD THE
INJUSTICE THAT I HAD BEEN
THROUGH.
SO MANY OTHERS.
BERNIE KERIK, FORMER NEW YORK
POLICE COMMISSIONER.
CHARLIE KIRK.
REV LEARNED FRANKLIN GRAHAM,
PASTORS MARK BURNS AND DARRELL
SCOTT, RANDY COGGINS, DYNAMIC
YOUNG EVANGELIST FROM FLORIDA,
THE ENTIRE FLYNN FAMILY,
GENERAL MIKE FLYNN, MAN WHO IS
STILL BEING PERSECUTED.
MY HATS OFF TO ALL OF THEM
BECAUSE THEY HELPED ME AND MY
WIFE AND MY FAMILY THROUGH THE
SCARIEST, MOST DIFFICULT PROCESS
YOU CAN IMAGINE.
BUT ABOVE ALL, I MUST TELL YOU,
SEAN, BASED ON ADVICE FROM YOU
AND REVEREND GRAHAM AND THE TWO
PASTORS THAT I MENTIONED, I
REALLY WANT TO THINK GOD BECAUSE
I WAS LITERALLY HOURS AWAY
FROM BEING SENT TO A COVID
INFESTED PRISON IN VIOLATION OF
CURRENT BUREAU OF PRISONS AND
DOJ POLICIES, IN VIOLATION OF
EVERY PRECEDENT IN THE COUNTRY
WHERE PEOPLE GOING TO JAIL OR IN
JAIL FOR ASKING FOR
COMPASSIONATE RELEASE, AND IN
EVERY CASE IT WAS GRANTED.
I AM 67 YEARS OLD.
I’VE HAD A LIFELONG PROBLEM,
RESPIRATORY PROBLEMS.
I WAS FACING WHAT I REALLY
BELIEVED WAS FUN NEAR DEATH
SENTENCE.
SO YOU, PARTICULARLY TUCKER,
MATT GAETZ AND EVERYBODY I
NAMED, MY HEART GOES OUT TO YOU.
I’M DEEPLY DEEPLY GRATEFUL BUT
MORE THAN ANYTHING ELSE, I AM
GRATEFUL FOR GOD BECAUSE AS YOU
TOLD ME, IF I WOULD REDEDICATE
MY LIFE, I WOULD BE REBORN.
I REMEMBER IT LIKE IT WAS
YESTERDAY AND YOUR ADVICE WAS
SOLID.
YOU SAID GOD WILL NEVER DESERT
YOU.
YOU WILL NEVER ABANDON YOU.
HE WILL PROTECT YOU IF YOU
CONFESS YOUR SINS AND YOU WALK
IN HIS WAY.
AND I’VE DONE MY VERY BEST TO DO
THAT.
>> Sean: LET ME GO THROUGH AND
I WANT YOU TO TELL PEOPLE,
BECAUSE THIS WHOLE SYSTEM OF
JUSTICE WHERE, SAMMY THE BULGUR
VINYL, THE BIGGEST CASE IN
POINT, HE COMMITS 19 MURDERS AND
GIVEN A GET-OUT-OF-JAIL-FREE
CARD AND A WITNESS PROTECTION
PROGRAM BECAUSE HE FLIPPED ON
JOHN GOTTI.
PUT THAT ASIDE FOR A SECOND, IN
YOUR CASE, DID MUELLER AND HIS
TEAM OFFER ANYTHING OF VALUE,
YOUR FREEDOM FOR EXAMPLE I WOULD
ARGUE IS OF GREAT VALUE IF YOU
WOULD SAY CERTAIN THINGS THEY
WANTED YOU TO SAY WHETHER THEY
WERE TRUE OR NOT.
>> IN THE BEGINNING OF THE CASE,
SEAN, I DON’T THINK THAT WAS
THEIR INTENTION.
BUT AS THEY GOT CLOSER AND
CLOSER TO HAVING TO ISSUE THE
MUELLER REPORT AND THEY REALIZED
THAT THEY HAD NO RUSSIAN
COLLUSION BECAUSE THERE WAS NO
RUSSIAN COLLUSION, IT WAS A
HOAX.
ON JULY 24, JEANNIE RHEE, WHO
WAS HEADING MY PROSECUTION
WITHIN THE MUELLER TEAM, THAT’S
EXTRAORDINARY IN ITSELF BECAUSE
SHE PREVIOUSLY REPRESENTED
HILLARY CLINTON AND THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION IN THE ILLEGAL EMAIL
SERVER CASE, THE MISSING EMAIL
CASE.
SHE HAD A CLEAR BIAS.
SHE WAS A MAXIMUM DONOR TO BOTH
OF HILLARY’S PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGNS.
BY THE WAY, SHE HAS ALL THE
CHARM OF A NORTH KOREAN PRISON
GUARD.
SHE MADE IT VERY CLEAR TO ONE OF
MY LAWYERS AFTER A HEARING, SHE
ASKED TO SEE THEM PRIVATELY,
THAT IF I WOULD REALLY REMEMBER
CERTAIN PHONE CONVERSATIONS I
HAD WITH CANDIDATE TRUMP, IF I
WOULD COME CLEAN, IF I WOULD
CONFESS, THAT THEY MIGHT BE
WILLING TO, YOU KNOW, RECOMMEND
LENIENCY TO TO THE JUDGE PARAGRA
I WOULDN’T EVEN SERVE ANY JAIL
TIME.
I DIDN’T HAVE TO THINK ABOUT IT
VERY LONG.
I SAID ABSOLUTELY NOT.
THERE WAS NO CIRCUMSTANCE UNDER
WHICH I WOULD BEAR FALSE WITNESS
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT.
I WAS JUST NOT WILLING TO LIVE.
NOW, IN THE LAST TWO DAYS WHEN I
SAID THAT, PEOPLE SAID YOU SEE
STONE HAD THE GOODS ON TRUMP AND
HE TRADED HIS SILENCE FOR
COMMUTATION.
THAT IS PATENTLY FALSE.
I NEVER SAID THAT.
I NEVER IMPLIED THAT.
WHAT I SAID HAS BEEN CONSISTENT,
THAT I WOULD NOT LIE AGAINST MY
FRIEND OF 40 YEARS SO THEY COULD
USE IT FOR IMPEACHMENT.
THEY WANTED ME TO BE THE HAM IN
THEIR HAM SANDWICH BECAUSE THEY
KNEW THE MUELLER REPORT,
PARTICULARLY ON RUSSIA, WAS A
DUD.
THEY HAD NOTHING.
THEY WERE HOPING THAT I WOULD
RECHARACTERIZE MY PHONE CALLS.
THESE PHONE CALLS THAT WERE
PLEA-BARGAIN-INDUCED CLAIMS BY
MICHAEL COHEN AND RICK GATES FOR
WHICH THEY COULD NEVER FIND ANY
COOPERATION, AND I SIMPLY
REFUSED TO DO IT.
>> Sean: LET ME GO TO DAVID
SCHOEN AND I WILL ASK YOU BOTH
THE SAME QUESTION
SIMULTANEOUSLY.
ROGER, I THINK I’VE KNOWN YOU
WELL ENOUGH OVER THE YEARS.
YOU’RE A FIGHTER.
YOUR INSTINCTS ARE GOING TO BE
OKAY, AND I’M GOING TO GO BACK
AND I’M -- MAYBE IF YOU GO BACK
AND YOU APPEAL THIS NEW OPEN UP
THIS CASE AGAIN, I WOULD ARGUE
RIGHT NOW YOU’RE HOME FREE.
AND I THINK THAT I SAW NOTHING
BUT CORRUPTION IN THAT COURTROOM
BY THE JUDGE IN THAT JURY THEY
NOT GIVING YOU ANOTHER TRIAL.
DAVID, I WOULD SAY THAT IF YOU
GO FORWARD WITH THAT, YOU’RE NOW
PUTTING ROGER’S LIFE BACK IN
JEOPARDY AGAIN.
AND I DON’T KNOW -- I DON’T HAVE
ANY FAITH IN THAT SYSTEM.
I DON’T HAVE ANY FAITH IN THAT
JUDGE.
I DON’T HAVE ANY FAITH WITH THAT
JURY.
NOBODY ON THIS CASE TO I BELIEVE
IS HONORABLE HERE.
>> I THINK YOU’RE RIGHT.
YOU RAISE AN INTERESTING
QUESTION AND A PERPLEXING ONE.
WE HAVE TO SIT DOWN AND MAKE A
DECISION AS TO WHETHER TO GO
FORWARD WITH THE APPEAL, KNOWING
A WIN IN THIS CASE AND THERE
SHOULD BE A WIN, CLASSIC FIFTH
AND SIXTH AMENDMENT VIOLATIONS,
WOULD GO TO THE SAME JUDGE IN A
COURTROOM OF INJUSTICE.
LET ME SAY TO YOU, THIS
COMMUTATION IS A GREAT TRIBUTE
TO PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR THREE
REASONS.
HE SENDS A MESSAGE THAT THEY
MUELLER TEAM WAS ROTTEN TO THE
CORE FROM ITS INCEPTION.
MR. MUELLER PICKED --
>> Sean: I’VE BEEN SAYING THAT
FOR OVER THREE YEARS, SCREAMING
AT.
>> YOU DON’T PICK, THE
INVESTIGATION THAT INVOLVED THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
REQUIRES INTEGRITY.
YOU DON’T PICK AND
ANDREW WEISSMANN WHO WAS THE
MOST ETHICALLY BANKRUPT
PROSECUTOR I’VE EVER COME
ACROSS.
I REPRESENT MEN RIGHT NOW WHO
WERE WRONGFULLY CONVICTED
WITH HIM, YOU TALKED ABOUT
MAKING DEALS WITH WITNESSES.
HE LIED ABOUT THOSE DEALS AND HE
MENTIONED SPECIFICALLY BY A
JUDGE FOR HIS MISCONDUCT.
THAT’S ONE THING.
THE MUELLER TEAM WAS RUN TO THE
CORPORATE FILLED WITH PARTISANS.
THE OTHER TWO, AN UNFAIR TRIAL.
THE PRESIDENT RECOGNIZED THAT,
THE JUDGE DENIED THE ENTIRE
DEFENSE THEORY.
MR. STONE WASN’T ALLOWED TO
MENTION ON SOCIAL MEDIA OR MAKE
A DEFENSE THEORY THAT IN ANY WAY
CHALLENGE THE INTEGRITY OF THE
MUELLER TEAM.
UNPRECEDENTED.
THIRDLY, THE PRESIDENT SAVED A
LIFE HERE BECAUSE THE JUDGE’S
DECISION ON DENYING A SURRENDER
EXTENSION WHEN COVID WAS IN THE
PRISONS AND WITH THESE HEALTH
CONDITIONS GOES AGAINST ALL
AUTHORITY IN THE COUNTRY ON THIS
ISSUE AS TO THE COURT OF
APPEALS.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, I’M
LISTENING TO YOUR ATTORNEY AND I
KNOW HAVE DAVID A LONG TIME,
I’VE KNOWN YOU’RE A LONG TIME,
ROGER.
YOUR CHARACTER.
EVERYONE KNOWS THAT.
IT’S NOT ABOUT YOU AS A
CHARACTER.
I WANT A FAIR AND IMPARTIAL JURY
FOR EVERYBODY.
IT WOULDN’T WANT A DEMOCRAT OR
LIBERAL TO HAVE 29 GUYS IN
TACTICAL GEAR OVER PROCESS
CRIME.
WOULDN’T WANT RUN ANY AMERICAN
THAT YOU HAVE A RIGHT TO SPEAK
OUT NARROW DEFENSE.
IT WOULD WANTED TO JURY FOR
PRISONERS PREJUDICE TOWARD A
JUDGE THAT WENT ALONG WITH THIS.
MY QUESTION TO YOU IS WE HAVE
SEEN THIS NOW WITH PAPADOPOULOS,
WE HAVE SEEN IT WITH
PAUL MANAFORT.
WE SIGNED WITH GENERAL FLYNN.
WE HAVE SEEN IT WITH YOU.
I’LL BE HONEST, ROGER.
I BELIEVE IN OUR CONSTITUTION.
I BELIEVE IN OUR RULE OF LAW.
I THINK I READ A LOT ABOUT EQUAL
JUSTICE AND APPLICATIONS OF OUR
LAWS.
I DON’T SEE THIS IN ANY OF THESE
CASES.
I SEE A TRAVESTY OF INJUSTICE.
YOU HAVE BEEN A PART OF IT.
I DON’T KNOW.
I’M LOSING FAITH IN THE SYSTEM,
ROGER.
>> WELL, YOU HAVE A GOOD REASON
TO.
YOU EXAMINE THE D.C. CIRCUIT
COURT OF APPEALS WHERE I HAD TO
FILE A LAST-MINUTE EMERGENCY
APPEAL OF JUDGE JACKSON’S ROOM
SENDING YOU TO JAIL.
SHE IGNORED ALL THE LEGAL
PRECEDENTS IN THAT.
SHE IGNORED MY HEALTH
CONDITIONS.
SHE IGNORE THE CONDITIONS AT THE
PRISON AT THAT TIME, AND SHE
IGNORED THE CURRENT POLICIES OF
DOJ AND THE BOC.
YOU WOULD’VE THOUGHT IT WOULDN’T
BEEN REVERSED IN THE APPEALS
COURT THE THEY RULED FOR HER
3-0.
I’M AFRAID THIS IS A FIXED
SYSTEM.
ABOVE ALL, THOUGH, I GUESS I
WOULD HAVE TO SAY THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING HERE IS THE
COURAGEOUS AND AS OF THE
PRESIDENT’S ACT.
I KNOW THERE WERE MANY, MANY
PEOPLE WHO TOLD HIM IN AN
ELECTION YEAR, DON’T DO THIS.
LET ROGER STONE WAIT FOR A
PARDON AFTER THE ELECTION.
SEAN, I DON’T THINK I WOULD HAVE
LIVE THAT LONG, NOT WITH MY
ASTHMATIC CONDITION.
NOT WITH NOW 60 COVID-19 CASES
IN THAT PRISON.
SO I HAVE DEEP AFFECTION FOR
DONALD TRUMP BECAUSE I’VE KNOWN
HIM 40 YEARS.
HE’S A MAN OF GREAT JUSTICE AND
FAIRNESS.
HE’S A MAN OF ENORMOUS COURAGE.
I KNEW HE WOULD TAKE SOME SHOTS
FOR THIS, BUT I THINK MOST
PEOPLE, MOST FAIR-MINDED PEOPLE,
UNDERSTAND HE SAVED MY LIFE AND
AT LEAST ON PAPER HE GAVE ME A
CHANCE TO FIGHT FOR VINDICATION.
I’M NOT A FOOL.
I’M GOING TO BE GUIDED BY THE
ADVICE OF MY LAWYERS.
AS I UNDERSTAND IT, IF MY
CONVICTION IS OVERTURNED BY THE
APPEALS COURT, I WOULD BE BACK
IN FRONT OF JUDGE JACKSON.
JUDGE JACKSON ISSUED AN
INCREDIBLE RULING THAT SAID THAT
I COULD NOT RAISE MISCONDUCT BY
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL, THE FBI,
THE DOJ, OR ANY MEMBER OF
CONGRESS.
ADAM SCHIFF.
SO I MEAN, IF THAT WERE IN
GENERAL FLYNN’S CASE, WE STILL
WOULDN’T KNOW HOW HE WAS
RAILROADED.
WE STILL WOULDN’T KNOW ABOUT THE
POLITICAL MOTIVATIONS BEHIND
TAKING HIM DOWN.
SO I’VE GOT TO BECOME CONVINCED
I CAN GET A FAIR SECOND TRIAL,
BECAUSE I CERTAINLY DIDN’T GET A
FAIR FIRST TRIAL.
>> Sean: YOU HAD A GAG ORDER
AND YOU WEREN’T ALLOWED TO EVEN
PUT ON YOUR DEFENSE.
YOU WANTED TO PUT ON A DEFENSE.
THEY DENIED YOU THAT RIGHT.
THEN OF COURSE WE HAVE THE JURY
FOR PERSON ON TOP OF THE PREDAWN
RAID.
I AM SURE YOU CALLED CNN, ROGER,
AND SAID THAT.
HERE IS, I DO NOT BELIEVE YOU
CAN GET ANY FAIR TRIAL IN THAT
COURT ROOM OR THAT SYSTEM.
I DON’T KNOW.
I THINK THAT PROBABLY EVERY
FIBER OF YOUR BEING WOULD WANT
TO BE TO FIGHT TO GET THE
ACQUITTAL.
YOU BELIEVE YOU SHOULD GET.
BUT I DON’T KNOW IF I GIVE YOU
THAT ADVICE BECAUSE I DON’T
THINK THERE’S ANYBODY IN THAT
COURTROOM THAT IS FAIR, ROGER.
>> AS YOU POINT OUT, COMEY,
CLAPPER, BRENNAN, McCAIG,
PETER STRZOK, LISA PAGE,
ROSENSTEIN, UHLER HIMSELF, HILLA
THEY ALL LIED UNDER
OATH THAT THEY LIED ABOUT
MATERIAL THINGS, CONSEQUENTIAL
THINGS.
THEY HAD AN INTENT AND MOTIVE TO
LIE.
I WAS CHARGED WITH MAKING THE
STATEMENTS THAT WERE INNOCUOUS.
IF YOU LOOK AT A VERY CAREFULLY,
IS VERY CLEAR WHAT HAPPENED
HERE.
THAT IS THAT AARON ZELINSKY, THE
CORRUPT PROSECUTOR, THE DIRTIEST
OF MUELLER’S DIRTY COPS OTHER
THAN WEISSMANN SHARE THE FRUITS
OF THE SURVEILLANCE TO ME WITH
ADAM SCHIFF SO THAT HE
COULD FASHION GOTCHA QUESTIONS,
MOST OF THEM OF NO CONSEQUENCE.
AND THEN AFTER THE SET UP IN
WHICH I APPEARED VOLUNTARILY
BEFORE THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE, SCHIFF IN VIOLATION
OF HOUSE RULES, SHARED THE
CLASSIFIED TESTIMONY WITH
MISTERS ZIELINSKI SO
MR. WEISSMANN COULD FASHION A
VERY CONTORTED AND CONTRIVED
INDICTMENT.
YET TODAY YOU HAVE MUELLER AND
SCHIFF AND ROSENSTEIN BACK TO
SAYING STONE WAS IN CAHOOTS WITH
RUSSIAN INTELLIGENCE.
THIS IS NONSENSE.
THEY ARE ALL THE WAY BACK TO THE
RUSSIA, RUSSIA, RUSSIA.
>> Sean: WAS THERE ANY
EVIDENCE OF THAT?
WAS THERE ANY EVIDENCE EVER
GIVEN OF ANY CONTACT WITH ANY
RUSSIAN INTELLIGENCE?
>> THERE WAS EVIDENCE THAT I HAD
A TWITTER DIRECT MESSAGE
EXCHANGE WITH LUCIFER .2.
A PERSONA.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHEN THAT
HAPPENS, IT HAPPENED LONG AFTER
WIKILEAKS HAD PUBLISHED ALL
THEIR MATERIAL.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE ACTUAL
CONTENT OF THE EXCHANGE, IT’S
BENIGN.
THERE IS NO COLLUSION.
THERE’S NO COLLABORATION.
AND THIRDLY WE DON’T EVEN KNOW
THAT GUCCIFER 2.0 IS A RUSSIAN
AGENT.
JUST BECAUSE JOHN BRENNAN SAID,
HE SAID THE STEELE DOSSIER WAS
TRUE.
I COULD HAVE PROVED AT TRIAL
USING FORENSIC EVIDENCE AND
EXPERT TESTIMONY FROM FELLOWS
LIKE THE FORMER SNA
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE EXPERT AND
RAY McGOVERN THAT NO ONE
HACKED THE DNC, THAT THERE WAS
NO ONLINE HACK OF THE DNC, THAT
THE INFORMATION BASED ON THE
DOWNLOAD TIMES WAS DOWNLOADED TO
A PORTABLE DESK AND TAKEN OUT
THE BACK DOOR.
BUT I WASN’T ALLOWED TO PRESENT
THAT DEFENSE BECAUSE
JUDGE JACKSON WOULD NOT ALLOW
IT.
>> Sean: ROGER, I WANT TO
BELIEVE IN OUR SYSTEM OF JUSTICE
AND IN THE WAY IT WORKED I GUESS
IN THE END WITH THE PRESIDENT’S
COMMUTATION.
BUT WHAT HAPPENED TO YOU, WHAT
HAPPENED TO PAPADOPOULOS, WHAT
HAPPENED TO GENERAL FLYNN, WHAT
HAPPENED TO HIM MANAFORT, WHAT
HAPPENED TO THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, WHAT HAPPENED TO
CARTER PAGE, WE ARE GOING TO
LOSE THIS COUNTRY IF THIS
HAPPENS AGAIN.
IT’S THE BIGGEST ABUSE OF POWER,
CORRUPTION SCANDAL IN OUR
HISTORY.
GLAD YOU’RE FREE TONIGHT, ROGER.